Thank you SIDA.
So the only thing that's a rubbish about great Britain is our rubbish rubbish.
And thank you for making that clear.
I'm going to tell you now the result of the vote, and again,
the reminder of this motion,
there's not much great about Britain and 36% of
you agreed with that.
And 35% of you were against,
uh, which means, um, based on the logic of the referendum result.
But it's a massive factory bar is Doug Smith and Dominic Cummings,
a massive factory for, and you should just feel, I mean,
why don't you just die? I, I,
I'm 29. Uh, Mimsy people,
29% of you utterly Mims. You don't even know what you think. Uh,
I'd be ashamed if I was one of you. Now we're going to have some questions,
get some lights up. Um, and while we're just doing that,
I want will tell us why he hasn't salted 3 million,
139,462 Welsh. Uh, by saying that they are failures.
How many Wells here in the audience has up? I'd miss it.
What are you going to say too? Are you going to be like Boris and go to Wales?
I think you should go to Cardiff now and apologize.
Like Boris had the decency to do, to go deliverable.
Well, it's, I'm moving to Wales myself. Actually. It's not about that.
It's about the fact that
Wales isn't relevant to this question. That's all.
That's a Weasley way out of that one. Now, Kate, do you love Britain?
I love the United Kingdom.
And do you love sport? I love sport.
And where you sports minister between 1999 and 2001.
And if you love great Britain,
and if you love your country and you love sport and you were sports minister,
how come under you?
The England football team and the wealth of the Scottish and Northern line
didn't even figure had their worst ever two years
does not make you just a little bit of time.
Um, funny enough, what a good question. Um, I,
if only this sports ministers could actually make the England team
win. Um, they would be prime minister and Tony Blair tried,
but he didn't win. Do you remember who the captain was?
Um, no, I didn't hide this. Let's move on rapidly. Uh,
where was John of Gordon born? Our hero. John of gone.
Where was he born again for, I think what I,
and how can you possibly think that it's all been down here?
What were the dates of John of Gordon, your hero?
I wouldn't say it was my hero quoted his dying speech or Shakespeare play.
We were moved to work that one side.
I also don't.
I don't know who the capsule of the English football team ever was.
And I don't care either.
Well, we do that. You didn't love your country.
You were stuck. Cause I knew where he was born. A man,
he takes games or a woman who takes games too seriously.
It means they don't take life.
I do picking out women, picking out women.
It's not about sport. It's got nothing to do with this at all.
Sorry. Is that a slightly sexist statement there about women and what's that
sexist statement about women take from well,
is that what you would expect from someone on that side? No, I think he, I look,
I really feel sorry for these guys, right? They're clearly scared of Britain.
They're scared of the new people that have arrived here. They're scared of
[inaudible]
you see what modern Britain represents for me is vibrancy.
And forward-looking unfortunately we have two men who are just looking back
and Hawking to a Britain that, so what was it like to be sad? Have the votes,
uh, when women are you sad?
I, I I'm, I'm deeply sad. Yes, obviously, but, uh, but it's Salida has spoiled.
What was extraordinarily good speech by this, this allegation,
which I think is quite wrong and it might be low as the tone of the discussion.
I'm very concerned about the future. Uh, the,
the past is gone and dead. You can't get it back, even if you wanted to. And,
uh, I have no yearning for it ticketing the 1950s, an age of gristle,
ashtrays and chilblains, but I done,
I w what we really do need to be very careful not to choose the
wrong future again. And honestly, I,
the question of sport, I,
the old Soviet union and the Warsaw pact countries spend an awful lot of time
and effort trying to Excel at sport and where that got them.
And they had very similar illusions about, uh, their importance, uh,
in the Soviet union. So the ones that we have now,
and that's one of the reasons why I take the position I do.
I saw what the results of those illusions was.
It's terrible collapse after living for many years in a fool's
paradise, which is what we are.
Well is looking at you with the look of a,
kind of a golden Labrador looking lovingly at his,
uh, Oh no. Are you laughing at.
Well on holiday together? People didn't realize that I love pizza.
Uh, are you happy to be sad? Huh? As, as they're saying.
No, I don't think we assigned at all on this side of things. I mean,
I think the problem is that what we heard from that end is,
um, basically we had a lot of extolling of a lot of patriotic
stuff and I think pizza, and I really tried to move debate onto some.
Serious questions here. And not just anybody, you know, Dr. Johnson said,
you know, patriotism, patriotism is the last refuge of the scoundrel.
Well,
I'm not suggesting there's something because he thought Patrick's ism was bad.
What he was drawing our attention to is that people who make their arguments on
the basis of patriotism are appealing to sentiment.
And that's not what Peter and I.
Okay. So we've got that. So your fantasies and scoundrels,
and those were just two of the nicer, I just, how does that feel?
Does that make you proud?
Yeah, I think, um, look, I liked lined a whole series of fact, you know,
these writers are fat. These musicians are fact these,
these, these, these,
the fact that a children's book,
the fact that it is the third most successful international
film franchise is fact and therefore what we have to,
we have to. Yeah,
but we have to celebrate those in our nation who are achieving
in all these fields.
It is fact that we are the sixth largest economy in the world. You know,
this is fact, and I think it is also fact, as I said,
and I gave my own real life example. There are many,
many people who start right at the bottom of the ladder.
And there are very few countries in the world which allowed the opportunities.
And we see the success of people who rise to play their
part at the top of finance art politics.
And we've of course, got to celebrate that.
Comment from a fantasy.
Oh, I can't, I can't understand how two people can sit there.
Having been educated in this country, gone to university.
I think both of you probably quite good universities, Oxford or Cambridge,
I imagine. Um,
and yet can't find a single thing to say will looks good
about this country.
Well, we're all we're arguing. We're arguing a case. That is,
who's not much.
Okay. Enough enough.
You wouldn't find the prosecution saying much for the defense either,
but it doesn't mean he doesn't know.
Well, if they got them slicing, that's marvelous.
I couldn't say sickly the love Fest in the room before.
Can we have the lights on and come? You have the first question, please? Yes,
we have questions. Why isn't a Christian number one? I could see two on three,
one. Let's have a question one here, please. A question one.
I'm going to take one, two and three. Yes. Let's go.
Let's take the rest of them. Question two then. Okay.
Can we have a question to commit the questions three that some of the hands up
someone? Yes. We got a question one. Let's go for question one. Yes. Good.
Sounds like a yes, sir.
Um, thanks everyone. Uh, for the, my question is.
At first, like you could find, um, flaws and faults in,
in any nation or anything, and it's kind of quite easy to be negative sometimes.
So are there any countries out there that you believe can truly claim to be
great? And if so, what makes them any different to us?
Uh, very good. Uh, clearly Belgium for Peter Hitchens,
where John and Gordon came from, or was it Holland? Um,
literally number two there, gentlemen, standing up.
Can we have some women to please?
Why is it nobody mentioned art glorious,
an attribute, gorgeous future under our pastiche prime minister.
Why is
nobody talked about our future one nationhood or our
global breadth, but because the two phrases,
all the references were backward looking,
everything was backward, looking, everything was utterly retrospective,
even the bad things were respite retrospect.
Nobody has any real competence in the confidence
trick currently being played on us by
ourselves as the look of a speech. Yes. Thank you very much, indeed.
I think that does can be,
we just had notation that from Peter York for the next debate. Ah,
thank you very much question please. Number three.
Hi. Um, so I'm um, with the ladies against the motion,
but I found Peter's comments very interesting.
And I would be interested in the panel's perception of how far
this, um,
I guess degration of our greatness has been because we've spent the
last few years being so critical of
ourselves and being very anti British as British and whether we're actually
devaluing ourselves through frankly wokeness
ultimately.
Well, I wrote Nass.
And does that mean you found didn't find well interesting.
You found pizza interesting.
Well, the most entertaining, but no,
I didn't find his views as interesting is
right.
Um, let's have a comment, uh, from Wil, uh, did you find that question?
Interesting and wokeness? Yes.
Well, I was making a technical point.
It's not a question of right or left or anything else.
It's just a technical point about cultures,
which is what we associate with hegemonic nations,
which is what's implied by great Britain in our, my argument was quite careful.
The gentleman who made the point about it all being about the past.
Peter said that the British army lost to the IRA in Northern Ireland,
the British army lost to the sadrist militia in Iraq only a few short
years ago and had to hang this to hands in shame as they were school cheat
back to the air point of disembarkation by the malicious defeated them.
So I'm not interested in the past.
I'm interested in right now on the point of wokeness. Yeah.
It's very difficult to imagine a hegemonic nation that is
truly multicultural. It's a contradiction in terms.
Look at the way that the current tag them on America gets its knickers in a
gigantic twist over trying to beat up people in foreign
countries while respecting the rights of its own minorities.
It's a pathetic spectacle. It's pathetic here as well.
Well, so self-hatred yep.
Well, I was going to talk about, um, I think the, the lady who,
even though she thought Chris Peter was interesting. Um,
I'm glad to hear that you think he was interesting.
She did the GSI thought Peter was interesting. Yes. Very interesting. Very,
very interesting. However, um,
I just wonder about her question because I think she's quite right. You know,
there's been a kind of bash Britain bash, British, uh,
feeling around in the country for some time now. And,
and I think eat no matter how much you support, um,
the motion tonight, I can't again understand how anyone,
if you travel around and go to other countries, yes, it's great to travel.
It's lovely to see other countries and there's some great things in them, but I,
I really cannot see any other country that combines the
kind of way that we have got our history.
And yet our history now is being moved forward in a direction that we're
becoming a country that is going to have to now rely on itself. Again,
is going to have to be, uh,
looking out globally and internationally and not relying on 26 other
countries to actually be along with what we're doing.
So I'm very optimistic and I think we should all stop, you know,
doing our country down and standing up for it the way other countries
populations do. And we seem to always want to be negative. Thank you very much.
Indeed.
I would like people to come to these microphones on the Vulcan is pleased to
have questions. I'd like to see a forest to people up there.
I'd like to see more questions coming out of the audience,
but while yes you can.
So I know I was only interesting, but I,
there was a point a point made about where we might want to look for an example
of somewhere that all suffers better. Well, this isn't anyway making any cases,
any other countries perfect,
or indeed that I would want to go and live in any other country,
but I can think of at least two countries where they all the things a lot better
than we do Switzerland seems to me, uh, to be extremely welded,
to have a much better, a much better arrangement of, um, uh,
of education of transport. It defends itself.
It doesn't go around invading other people's countries, uh,
as a whim for nurses in militia for no good reason. Uh, and it's,
it is extremely free and has an extraordinarily.
Democratic system. It's not the same as ours,
but it has much to recommend it to my role.
So I spent a lot of my life traveling through other countries.
And one of the things that I learned during that trial was to stop looking at
them and wondering why they couldn't be more like Britain and seeing if I could
learn things from them,
another country from which we could learn a great deal is Japan, uh,
which has many of the characteristics, which we admire and ourselves,
which we no longer really possess such as the politeness and
civility, which it seems to me that in many cases we are losing, uh,
that it's all very well saying that people say, sorry to each other,
that you should try riding a bicycle in London and see if anybody says, sorry,
see you a lot of them too. So I think that, yes,
there are places we could look to,
but one of the things that we really do need to do and any,
any real Patriot is his country's most severe critic because then
he real Patrick truly cares about all
those pants, a, a ridiculous technical, a tourist boarding Lin swings,
like a pendulum do picture of the kind of bodies on bicycles,
two by two rubbish about what it's really like here, because it isn't, uh,
the police may not be corrupted in this country,
but they are almost totally absent, uh, which is a much bigger problem.
Peter moved to Japan, which is he thinks is a great country. No,
I don't think he should, because as everybody keeps saying,
he's very interesting. Um, and we need,
we need to have interesting
to have interesting people in this country, but I think it's also important.
I mean, when I do agree with, with both, uh, the, the, uh,
panelists opposite is that I think it is important for us to be a realistic and
for us to challenge,
but to do it in a way where we do accurately measure ourselves against other
countries, you know, as foreign office minister,
I spent a lot of my time traveling around meeting and getting to know
countries incredibly deeply and what we
just take for granted, which I, you know, I, let me speak very personally,
I, as a woman take for granted about how I travel,
where I travel, what I can say, which I, as a politician say,
in terms of what I can say, how I can say it,
these things are just not even available in many, many nations around the world.
So what I'm saying is, um,
we're not arguing here about whether we are the greatest nation in the world.
What we are arguing is that, that motion, there's not much great about Britain.
I tell you that is a lot. That is great.
So when you do me a favor,
ask Kate now what you saw at East Croydon on her way back from,
from Gatwick airport, Oscar, what.
I saw a stabbing. Yes, of course.
But does that really say Chris or Peter that this is not going on elsewhere?
I was in Frankfurt recently at a football match actually. Um, I,
Ryan Frankfort station,
it was absolutely impossible to walk with our gangs of young people,
mainly not Germans all hanging around or taking drugs,
which I know some people think is fine. And then, um,
there was a real feeling of fear, not, I don't think,
no matter how terrible things are in London at the moment with was with
stabbings.
And it was a very frightening experience that people walk around in fear.
And I do think that you can't judge a country by, can I just come back on this?
And you know, th the kind of time that you described, uh, you know,
when we could build railways in seven days and we could kind of build ships in
five days and we could go around the world, defeating the world in world Wars.
Do you think that it was any safer to walk around the East end of London then,
but we still thought we were, if you, if we would a great country then,
and we had crime in London, just having crime in London today.
Actually. Yes, actually. Yes, it was. And all the accounts at the time,
there was a huge
[inaudible] if you asked the question and he was listened to the answer,
there was a, there was a huge defeat of crime and disorder in this country,
uh, brought about by water. Now,
the geodesic Victorian values at the end of the 19th century,
which we continue to benefit from to some extent even now, but we are losing.
Okay. I wanted to get, move into more questions.
Now you can ask questions of the fantasy or the optimist. Well,
before we do that, can you just name please?
Your one country that you think is great because.
I don't think any, uh,
arm's going to end on my point about status and nation States,
and I'd like to keep my powder dry, right?
How to dry up powder dry. Well, you're going to have a question out. Yeah,
please. Yes. From the balcony, an excellent question coming on.
I wondered if you could touch upon.
How English and Welsh law is the governing law for most international
contracts and how you feel that relates to this motion.
Well, that's going to get them on the edge of their seat. Uh,
thank you very much in Pete. If you want us to the question.
Thank you very much for that. Um, and the question about waving over there. Yes.
Let's go for this one here.
Well, this is for you. Hi there. Where are you? Here? Are there you are. Hi,
listen, you were hilariously. I wateringly depressing,
but I have to say there was one thing you said that it was Hagerman that the
great came into Britain because we were a big empire. Well,
when Kate was talking about what makes her move, it was the United Kingdom.
It was James F. I was blown away when I found out that James,
the first of Scotland was the first person to put the great into Britain.
That's in 60, no three.
Okay. And the question is, does he know?
And is that the greatness has the great,
these tiny.
Islands have grown exponentially in their influence.
And when Syeda talked about the Commonwealth,
I would love her to expand a little bit more about how she sees the future with
all those 53 countries who genuinely
have a Goodwill.
Right. Okay. Um, I'm just gonna remind you here again.
You should be voting if you haven't already done so either yes or no.
If you can't make your, uh, if you were in the Mimsy brigade, right.
And question it down here and you don't know question yes. Question here. I'll,
let's have other, there is a lady in the third row back.
Let's give lady in the second row back. And there you are question a up,
you Stan. This is the question now, please. Nothing about contracts.
No, I don't understand it all. Hello.
Um, this is the question to say,
either you do mention about all the facilities that people enjoy, you know,
being British, you know, like the free schooling, the NHS, the transport,
but would you not say that the quality of the services have fallen over the
years in order to remain great?
Should not the quality of the services be better?
Yeah. And do you think that your,
the conservative leader of your party,
Boris Johnson is going to really put the G back into great.
Well, because this is clearly being filmed and there's going to be a podcast.
Yes, of course. I believe that, Anthony, what would you expect me to say?
Well, I didn't know whether he wanted a job in the cabinet.
Proving out how fantastically English you are by being a massive hypocrite.
But I I've probably followed Peter's advice and decided that civility has to
prevail. And what is your view about, about the, the,
the contract point, but I didn't hear that question. We didn't,
it doesn't normally affect you. Whether you hear the question,
I'm going to just give the answer that I'm, you're a politician. Uh,
I think hearing the question is a profoundly relevance. Uh, well,
let's hear your views about.
This on contract law. Yes.
On the three questions. Really? Yes. Well, I think a lot of people.
One of the things the city sells, it's a financial jiggery.
Pokery on his due diligence and their idea of the rule of law in this
country. And that that's an extremely important thing.
And one of the things that makes Britain great,
isn't it great that really dodgy finances and business
people from other countries can come here and we'll be an honest broker for
their deals. So what a great country.
On the subject to that S word haven't you got an S word you're going to share
with us tonight. Say that I shared it right at the beginning. This,
hear it again.
I said that two guys were here telling everybody that we lived in a
hole and I don't agree with it.
Do you think that's a fair summary of that intelligence?
Well,
I do think this is not the first summary and anybody listening with a fair mind
knows that it's not what I do think. And I rebuke both will.
And or is that the use of words like that in public places is a sign of the
decline of our.
Cool.
If you can't,
you can't express yourself without resourcing to the language of the lavatory
wall, then you can't express yourself. And I.
Uh, w w w what about
[inaudible]?
So, Peter, because it's just not true.
I've expressed myself in many, many,
many volumes and can use lots of other words,
but I don't think that the use of the word,
the S word in this context was not inappropriate.
I appreciate inside you using it. She's used it with conviction,
and I used it as well with some convention to after all we'll produce it,
Peter, or perhaps you're in a different stage of development.
You're now you're looking at.
But the point is we produce as well as we used to,
or it's the going down the plug hole too.
Well, that's our next holiday gone? I don't, I think it is important.
Civility is important.
The use of language is important and the language is what separates us from the
animals. And if we don't use it with care and thought, uh,
then w with throwing away an important gift.
And I think this descent into, for lesser language, uh,
which is common to politics and to journalism and to even into literature and
on television has been a lowering of our culture.
And the, the whole point I was.
So when I went to live in the Soviet union in 1990,
I was taught by my by teacher, uh,
the extremely elaborates, uh,
filthy language of Russia. And at the end of it,
my teacher said a name was promised me never to use any of this.
You must know what it means. It's tremendously dangerous to use it,
because this is the line between normal life and violence. This is this,
this is a very tight, be coded, very subtle form of language. And if you,
if you use it wrongly, you might well be killed,
but you need to know what it means, but I'm telling you this for that reason.
And that is the purpose of this language. Is there are moments.
I've no doubt that when my father was going on to and between Murmansk and
scarper flow in his Majesty's ships in the 1940s was of this kind.
We used on the bridge from time to time, perhaps with good reason,
but those on people, don't coal mines. And in trawlers,
might've used them as well, because they were justified.
They're not justified here. And I don't think people should lightly use them.
And I think they should constrain themselves.
And by doing so express themselves better, we, the tremendously rich.
Language always offers who saw you to list it
that time, struggling to find any possible relevance to what this
[inaudible] has got about the title of this debate. Kate,
do you disagree with sight as use of the S word very briefly?
Or are you going to fall out like.
Well, I personally would not,
I never have used what would be called words like that in
public. I think I haven't, and I don't see why people laugh with that.
There is a, there is a problem with our society,
and it doesn't mean that I don't think this motion is nonsense,
but there is a problem with our society that we are actually devaluing a lot
of the kind of
ways that people behaved and that we were taught to behave have now been
kind of almost thrown out the window. And it's almost laughed at now.
If people are, are, are polite. If people actually say, thank you.
If people give up their seat, I'm very delighted.
If a man gives me a seat or a woman gives me a seat as well,
if they want to on a tube and all of these things we alert and we saw in
parliament, what was wrong in the last couple of years?
Not just because we had an appalling speaker who allowed things to completely
get out of control,
but we have lost all respect and no wonder people are losing respect and
politicians.
Very good. Okay. Thank you very much, indeed. For that. Kate,
we're going to just take three final questions that I'm trying to
get a fair cross section. Uh, there is a gentleman here.
There's a lady in the third row there,
and I'm going to go for a lady. Um,
who's got her hand up there. So let's go one, two, three short snappy questions.
No S words. Um.
Now Anthony, I know you're on a education list, um,
but I have to disagree with the Baroness about your
idea about social movement in the UK.
And this is because I agree with Peter,
the educational system in this country is deeply unfair.
The same people rise to the top,
the same people get all the privileged positions.
That is the worst thing about Britain, the lack of social movement,
the lack of opportunity for the majority of our children, young people,
it's holding us back. And it's very, very.
And does that detract from this being great, right. Okay. Significant, uh,
a very significant point. Let's take this question there. Yes, please.
Uh, my questions to Kate, um, well, you touched on it at the beginning, um,
your historics poor of the Fox hunting and in your speech
side, uh,
you mentioned our ability as a nation to be really forward thinking and how
we're consistently behind revolutionary thought.
And I just wondered how Kate feels that fits in one,
her attitudes to animal rights,
which is arguably at the forefront of revolutionary thinking and particularly
amongst.
Kind of the younger population of this country,
why it's very antithetical to our advancement in that area of evolution.
Okay. Thank you very much. And then the final question here, gentlemen,
at the end, and these will be the last set of questions.
Um, my questions were K and it's a simple question regarding Brexit
where isn't Brexit, one of the gross,
most grandiose displays of Britain bashing,
and you supported it yourself and isn't that kind of a Mark of hypocrisy
because you mobilize and engage with Britain bashing.
And now you're coming out and saying that we shouldn't bash Britain and we live
in some sort of Panglossian grip best of all worlds.
Right. Okay. Um, thank you very much, indeed. Uh,
that I'm going to ask you to bear in mind, uh,
those questions and in your final summative comments,
which will be 90 seconds, uh, each,
and we're going to go in reverse what it means.
It's going to begin with Syeda said picking up those three points and any other
summative points that you want to make. I now have the score here,
which I'm going to announce at the end, but, uh,
off from work from your day.
Okay. Um, so I think the question that you asked me, uh,
really goes to the heart of this debate and that is that, uh,
can Britain be better?
Social mobility is definitely on the decline and there are countries around the
world that have better social mobility, and that leads to better community,
a more integrated nation. Canada is one example, the bigger,
the divide between the rich and poor, the more, less cohesive the country is,
but just because we can do better and we absolutely can do better in all of the
areas that I mentioned we can do better.
That does not mean that we are still not a great country,
a great nation. And therefore, what I would ask you tonight,
ladies and gentlemen is to choose hope over despair.
I would choose you, ask you to choose optimism over pessimism.
And I would ask you to vote against this motion to vote for team
burgundy, team Britain and not to vote for team gray,
team pessimistic, man, flu. Thank you.
Well, um,
pizza, how would you respond in the final?
Well, I'm not going to do that because I know all the votes being counted.
Anyway, I take out, I take advantage of the, a,
of the question from the lady down there on the, on,
on our education system until the throne,
even war news was brought to even war that his old friend Randolph Churchill,
uh, had been taken into hospital for an operation to remove a non-malignant
growth.
And even in war responded by saying how extraordinary the medical profession to
rummage through the whole body of Randolph Churchill and find the only thing
which is not malignant and remove it.
And this sums up the education policy of this country, which in 1965,
found that it had some tremendous state ground schools,
which had lifted tens of thousands of people out of, out of poverty into,
into totally new lives, benefited the country immensely by their talents.
And it had bad secondary modern schools, which were failing to do this.
And so what did you do?
It closed the grammar schools and turned them all into secondary moderns.
And this is one of the reasons why we are a country,
which is in serious need of, uh,
how shall I put it something close to the approaching cultural revolution.
And I very much hope that that's what we have, but if we don't,
then maybe it'd be some of you will go away from this evening thinking that
things are not quite as great as you thought they were. And as a result,
we might conceivably survive as a country rather than sink giggling into the
sea.
Thank you very much, PISA Kate.
And can you particularly pick up the boys on animal rights?
I am amazed this whole thing about Fox hunting. I mean,
I think it's because we're lives in lumbers and there's so many foxes.
You actually spend half your life watching them don't you will,
but Fox hunting for me was something that as far as I'm concerned,
there has to be wildlife management.
Anyone who doesn't think that doesn't know anything about the countryside.
And as far as I was concerned, hunting was as, as,
as good and as better away than shooting foxes,
who then die and misery and all of that, it was a libertarian issue to me.
I don't know why it's been such a big issue tonight.
I'm fed up with people going on about animal rights.
What I want is to see animal welfare and I want to Pete,
and I just think we've become very woke using that term when it comes to
animals. Nobody,
I was brought up on a farm where there was absolutely no cruelty,
but I'm fed up with people.
Assuming somehow that animals have got some kind of special status that we have
to, uh, behave in that way. Um, on, on the question, just going,
I must say that I don't understand where you got the word hypocrite.
I haven't bashed Britain ever in terms of the Brexit,
the bit I've bashed the European union and will continue to do so. Uh,
only now we're not going to be part of it anymore. Um, I have never bashed the,
our country. I thought that we would want it.
I wanted to see us being independent. It wasn't about trading for me.
It was about actually having a country that could very much be independent again
and making its own in charge of its own destiny and not responsible and working
towards the European union, but just on this overall, the debate,
this really is, as Aida has said,
it's about whether you actually think that this country has got
things in it that you know, would not be happening in other countries.
And that what is great about our country is that we can actually have these
kinds of debates that people on the whole are quite nice to each other
afterwards. And before, um, that in the end.
We know that our country is, is going now into it and exciting fears.
And what I would like to see is that everybody gets behind that and makes the
country really grit. And for me,
grit does not mean that you agree with everything that it does,
but it certainly means that it's,
it's a lot better than many of the countries I've visited nights.
Why so many of us are living here and could move,
but don't move because we love our country. Thank you very much. Kate Hoey
and lifting the whole debate. Anna, who knows,
who knows maybe even changing the result that I have written down on this paper
by the sheer magnetism and power of your speech.
Thank you, Nancy, for that belt. I don't, I don't know where to begin.
Just on a sidebar Oliver Rakim,
the preeminent historian of the English countryside writes that the Fox would
have been eradicated in this country several hundred years ago,
written not for the desire of certain group of the Gentry to hunted.
So it's been artificially kept alive in order to be hunted.
And you best hope that animals do have some rights because you're an animal
and you don't have any human rights if you don't have any animal rights,
but that's just a side bar.
What I wanted to talk about really was you it's too late.
You voted I've shame on you. If you voted for them,
really the baronesses speech was the nearest sort of Hovis advert
winsy. Uh,
and as for my Quando men P that she Rose to the rhetorical
Heights that as I said before, you know, mistrust,
a woman who takes games to seriously mean she doesn't take games seriously
enough, but both of them attacked us really on the line of patriotism.
And that's not what Peter and I were really talking about, but, you know,
I got a little time. So I'll tell you a joke.
My mother was an immigrant to this country from the States, a Jewish American.
So I can tell a Jewish joke. She used to say, by the way,
the difference between the States and here was an America,
they hate you because you're a woman or because you're black or because you're a
Jew and here in England, they just hate you personally.
[Inaudible].
Totally happened to be a woman black or a Jew. Great,
great country.
Thank you well, very much. And, um,
for that, uh, elevating, uh, very elevating, uh, joke,
uh, which is going to leave, everyone's going to be leaving, uh,
with a spring in their heels. I thought that was,
I thought they did incredibly well. They've managed to be very insulting, uh,
to each other are between the teams and even within the team on my right hand
side. Um,
we got rid of that sheer hypocrisy of that comradery at the beginning.
And I don't want to see any of it up in the green room afterwards. Uh,
I want you just to walk off in a half, um, that will mean it's been a really,
even better debate. Now look, it was so, um, uh, it's so,
uh, significant the vote before 29% didn't know what to
think or who they were, uh, 36% voted for the motion.
There's not much great about, uh,
Britain and 35%. Uh,
now the 29% undecided have gone down to
3% of variance. It tells me of minus 26. So,
uh, that is saying something for the education system, uh,
will that it could be enormously, uh, better. Uh,
the variance was 13% on the others and by, uh,
a, uh,
massive overwhelming and triumphant margin,
uh, the motion has been lost
Yes by you. How does that feel?
You're losing you lose it and it's been won by the
depressing [inaudible].
I got your throat. Well,
thank you very much. That was 49,
49 to 48. Eat your heart out. Dominic Cummings.
They says massive, massive factory.
I'm can ask all of you for coming and being a fantastic audience,
possibly the best audience ever for an intelligent spread debate and can thank
intelligence squared and the speakers. One more time. Thanks.
[Inaudible].